[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 60,18 l'actualité locale
en 26 minutes tout de suite les titres
de ce mercredi 5 septembre était
ensoleillé dans les yvelines était
également au beau fixe pour le secteur
du tourisme les principaux sites du
département ont enregistré pour la
plupart une hausse de leur fréquentation
un reportage notamment à france
miniature élan cloud qui a connu sa plus
belle saison depuis 13 ans ce sera l'une
des stars de l'événement à côté des
joueurs pour accueillir le public de la
ryder cup une tribune g en seconde en ce
moment au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à 22 mètres de
haut 6000 à 800 places assisses est la
plus grande de l'histoire de la
compétition enfreint enfin on prendra un
peu de hauteur à la fin de ce journal
pour faire la connaissance du vautour
l'espace rambouillet proposait de
découvrir le rapace à l'occasion de la
journée internationale qui lui est
consacré un animal utiles à l'écosystème
dont l'existence est menacée tout à
l'heure également avec nos emplettes aux
deux invités michel callot président de
la fédération française de cyclisme qui
viendra elle nous parlait de la coupe du
monde sur piste au vélodrome nationale
nous recevons également alexis boulet
qui a réalisé un film hommage à la
nature en vallée de chevreuse mais
d'abord elle brigue la plus haute
fonction de l'assemblée nationale à yale
brune peavey est candidate à la
présidence de la chambre pour succéder à
françois de rugy nommé ministre de
l'écologie est la députée elle rit même
des yvelines est en lice pour son parti
tout comme son homologue richard ferrand
un vote interne de la république en
marche doit désigner le candidat à lundi
prochain les 577 députés désigneront
ensuite mercredi le nouveau président et
si c'est un richard ferrand qui est élue
elle la députée des yvelines
aurore bergé pourrait prendre sa
succession à la tête du groupe l em à
l'assemblée nationale l'inspecteur
académique serge clément l'a confirmé
hier dans ce journal des derniers
ajustements de la carte scolaire du
département ont été effectués en cette
rentrée quatre classes supplémentaires
ouvrent sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines dont des écoles
maternelles à chaque fois il s'agit des
établissements du chapiteau à maurepas
des sceaux
à montigny le bretonneux est de la
boissière à plaisir et de stendhal à
trappes
al'inverse une classe ferme à voisins le
bretonneux à l'école maternelle des
pépinières est le comité régional du
tourisme a dévoilé les chiffres de la
fréquentation touristique sur le premier
semestre ils sont très bons l'île de
france a enregistré à 17,1 millions est
arrivé hôtelière une augmentation de
plus de 4% sur un an est des chiffres
qui devraient encore s'améliorer avec
l'excellente fréquentation cet été dans
les yvelines les sites ont fait le plein
les détails avec michael ni droit la
saison estivale 2018 a été un très grand
cru pour le tourisme illinois le château
de versailles a vu sa fréquentation
augmenter de 0 3% depuis le début de
l'année à moins de 40 kilomètres le parc
zoologique de thoiry qui fêtait cette
année ses 50 ans a lui aussi connu un
très bel été avec cent trente six mille
visiteurs en deux mois
des gens qui habitent effectivement dans
les yvelines et aux alentours sont venus
parce qu'il faisait beau parce qu'on a
fait parlez-nous avec plein de
nouveautés
voilà les trois raisons cette année
france miniature avait misé sur la voix
de l'animateur stéphane bern pour
présenter 12 de ses monuments
historiques à paris payants plus de 68
mille curieux ont investi le parc élan
courtois sur juillet août la saison
estivale la plus prolifique depuis 13
ans mais l'afflux de visiteurs a été
variable sur les deux mois il ya eu des
trous d'air on va dire dans cette
fréquentation puisque la coupe du monde
à a été un peu particulière les français
sont arrivés loin et ont gagné la finale
et du coup les visiteurs soit un peu
moins sorti sur cette période et on a
connu également un petit trou d'air avec
la canicule qui a aussi différé les 18,3
dia votre site touristique le château de
breteuil a réalisé le deuxième plus bel
été de son histoire une influence qui
devrait permettre à la structure de
dépasser la barre des 125 mille
visiteurs en 2018
les chiffres qui aurait pu exploser si
la région n'avait pas été frappée par la
canicule au mois d'août un jour de
canicule
habituellement on fait entre 200 et 200
personnes sans problème un jour d'été au
x 320 10 ans de 300 on est passé à 100 à
peu près ont séjourné là mais on a
rattrapé pas mal sur le 2
perry du mois d'août ou envers le pape
et enfin trapil de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines enregistré une
augmentation du nombre d'entrées de 15%
entre le 15 juillet et le 19 août par
rapport à l'année dernière
la saison touristique n'est peut-être
pas encore terminé avec l'été indien qui
se profile dans les yvelines au mois de
septembre
c'est l'un des chantiers est fort du
moment à saint quentin en yvelines les
travaux du pont fuller visant à doubler
les bois pour fluidifier le trafic est
bien avancé cet été la partie nouvelle
de l'édifice qui relie maurepas à la
gare de la verrière est terminée il est
prévu de faire basculer la circulation
sur les voies neuves à partir du 7
septembre
une ultime phase va débuter désormais la
reconfiguration de l'ancien pont
revêtement des trottoirs couche de
roulement renouvellement du garde-corps
fin des travaux prévue en novembre
elle aussi est en chantier en ce moment
au golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines pour accueillir le public de la
ryder cup du 25 au 30 septembre est les
organisateurs ont décidé de faire
construire une tribune géante avec une
capacité est de 6000 à 800 places c'est
la plus grande de l'histoire de la
compétition nickel et demi d'euros 22
mètres de haut si 1800 places assises
avec cette super tribune la ryder cup
2018 est déjà inscrite dans l'histoire
de la compétition avant même d'avoir
commencé sa capacité cinq fois
supérieure à celle de la dernière
édition organisée en 2016 aux états unis
et joueurs amateurs du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines n'en
reviennent pas à les impressionnantes
allait elle est belle elle est grande
pour le départ du 1 c'est parfait elle
est immense
j'ai entendu dire qu'elle faisait 6000
places je suis impressionné la tribune
éphémère encore en cours de construction
permettrait d'avoir une vision sur 11
des 18 trous du parcours
les spectateurs pourront notamment voir
le premier coup de la compétition le
vendredi 28 septembre l'ambiance autre
numéro 1 est devenu quelque chose dans
l'héritage de la ryder cup c'est
mythique l'ambiance quand tu les veux
rentrer dans l'arène et ce bruit
assourdissant donc je pense qu'on a
voulu l'amplifier encore plus parce que
non seulement il ya les 6800 personnes à
6 mais il y aura aussi
la même voire dix mille personnes debout
pour avoir sa place dans cette tribune
et spectateurs devront faire sonner le
réveil entre 5 heures et 6 heures du
matin objectif être les premiers à
accéder au site
il ya des placements dans la tribune un
peu derrière un peu plus bas plus près
du départ du 1 qui qu'on pouvait au gré
des notes billets pour préserver la
place mais sur les 6800 place il ya
simplement 1000 places qui ont été
préservés
il ya 1800 c'est pour toute personne qui
est sur le site bien habillés ils ont
accès ici à la tribune en parallèle de
cette superstructure le golf a vu se
dresser des pavillons et des tribunes
pouvant accueillir des milliers de
spectateurs sur le parcours
l'ensemble sera livré au plus tard le 19
septembre avant le passage des
différentes commissions de sécurité est
une légende du golf sera sur le green
saint quentinois c'est officiel tiger
woods participera la ryder cup à la fin
du mois il a été retenu par le capitaine
de l'équipe américaine jim furyk aux
côtés de phil mickelson et de brighton
de chambaud cette sélection récompense
les derniers bons résultats du golfeur
une sixième place au british open en
juillet et un retour dans le top 30
mondial cela faisait six ans que tiger
woods ne participait pas à la ryder cup
et ça sera une deuxième pour lui au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
après un passage en 1994 lorsqu'il
n'était encore qu'un joueur amateur
côté européen à noter que les quatre
derniers membres de la sélection pour la
ryder cup sont connus le capitaine
thomas bjorn a choisi des golfeurs
expérimenté l'espagnol sergio garcia le
suédois henrik stenson ainsi que les
britanniques paul casey et ian poulter
le premier invité de ce journal est avec
moi en plateau michel callot bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le président de la
fédération française de cyclisme
merci d'être avec nous sur ce plateau
alors avant de parler de votre sport une
réaction peut être sur la présence de
tiger woods à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
d'avoir une légende du golf une légende
du sport ici sur ce territoire est ce
que c'est une chance je crois à quels
que soient les événements sportifs c'est
sûr que quand on peut avoir la chance de
mobiliser une légende de son sport c'est
toujours un point très important et est
ailleurs route incarne tellement de
choses autour du golf que
je crois effectivement que c'est une
vraie opportunité pour le territoire de
la voir dans cette compétition qui parle
d'ailleurs aux amateurs de golf mais
aussi à ceux qui ne connaissent pas
forcément
le golf le nom de tiger woods évoque
beaucoup revenu au cyclisme le vélodrome
de national de saint quentin en yvelines
où les locaux de votre fédération sont
implantés à s'apprête également à
recevoir un grand événement c'est la
première manche de la coupe du monde sur
piste us et y 2018-2019 c'est du
vendredi 19 au dimanche 21 octobre en
2015 rappelons que l'enceinte
saint-quentinoise avait reçu les
championnats du monde sur piste une
question simple et aussi pour donner
toutes les clés à nos téléspectateurs
quelle est la différence entre un
championnat du monde et une coupe du
monde alors un championnat du monde est
un événement unique sur une sur une
seule journée en tous les cas une
journée par épreuve où sont décernés les
titres de champion du monde donc c'est
le meilleur ce jour là qui remporte le
titre de champion du monde d'accord du
monde c'est un événement un épisode on a
une série de coupes du monde six ou sept
selon les années et c'est à l'issue de
cette série de compétitions que sont
décernés les les récompenses des
meilleurs nations donc une première
manche ça va se poursuivre tout au long
de la saison dans d'autres lieux du
monde
oui absolument c'est très internationale
la piste et intercontinental on aura une
manche en allemagne on aura une manche
en angleterre une manche à hong kong par
exemple là où étaient les championnats
du monde il ya deux ans donc on a
souvent une répétition finalement entre
ces événements mondiaux championnats du
monde coupe du monde sur les plus grands
vélodrome de la planète vous avez
accueilli cette année une autre coupe du
monde celle de bmx étaient les deux
premières manches qui se déroulait au
printemps c'était une réussite cette
organisation
cette organisation a été une grande
réussite d'abord sur le plan de la
participation jamais une épreuve de
coupe du coupe du monde avait accueilli
autant de pilotes en bmx sur un même
site donc ça c'est une vraie performance
pour nos équipes
et puis je crois que c'était un grand
succès populaire aussi puisqu'on a joué
à guichet fermé comme on dit donc toutes
les places sont son parti on a même
refusé malheureusement d accès
certains spectateurs qui voulaient venir
nous rejoindre on parlait de
l'organisation des championnats du monde
avant 2015 dans sa jeune histoire le
vélodrome a aussi accueilli des
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste des manches de coupe de france
il y aura aussi les légions en 2024 des
des épreuves des jo qui seront
organisées sur place ça prouve que c'est
une enceinte de renommée mondiale
ce vélodrome oui incontestablement déjà
par sa structure c'est un vélodrome qui
a une largeur assez exceptionnel
c'est une piste rapide il est récente
donc encore toutes ses caractéristiques
et cette piste permet d'une part aux
compétiteurs de pouvoir découvrir ce que
sera le site olympique ce qui est
important pour pour des pistes à
reprendre des points de repère et puis
d'autre part c'est une piste qui peut
être propice à des records donc à des
performances de très très haut niveau
alors pour présenter la compétition
n'aura bien sûr sur cette manche de
coupe du monde les la crème du cyclisme
sur piste mondiale 25 pays représentés
d'autant il faut le préciser que ces
sept manches de coupe du monde et est
qualificative pour les jo de tokyo en
2020 voilà bon alors on va démarrer avec
avec cette manche ici à saint quentin en
yvelines
l'étape où les étapes qui vont mener
vers les jeux olympiques c'est la
première manche qui donnera des points
dans les différentes disciplines de la
piste pour pause qualifiés et c'est
aussi pour ça que cette manche est
importante pour nos athlètes puisque
pouvoir le faire à domicile c'est quand
même se donner un petit avantage dans la
maîtrise justement de la piste et on
espère que nos athlètes dont tirer
profit de cet avantage et on aura bien
sûr des français présents la jeune
génération notamment mathilde gros
sébastien vigion j'en à thomas pour ne
citer qu'eux ils vont de réelles chances
sur sur cette coupe du monde
oui absolument c'est une coupe du monde
qu'on va aborder avec notre ambition
c'est un objectif à part entière dans la
saison qu'il abhorre une saison
hivernale le cyclisme sur piste et aussi
bien sûr les disciplines de
du sprint avec notamment sébastien
vigier mathilde gros mais qui sont les
leaders d'une équipe assez complète
quand même que sur les disciplines
d'endurance avec effectivement benjamin
thomas mais également une équipe de
poursuite par équipe qu'on aimerait bien
voir arriver au moins en demi-finale
pour concrétiser une progression qu'on
consent à venir année après année une
compétition à domicile vous attendez
combien de spectateurs sur un tel
événement alors on espère faire le plein
du vélodrome sur les trois soirées pour
pour mémoire le vélodrome c'est 5000
places assises donc et la
commercialisation la billetterie en tous
les cas est ouverte
donc on fait le maximum pour que le
groupe soit plaint parce que en dehors
de l'enjeu économique évidemment autour
d'un événement de remplir le la
billetterie l'autre enjeu c'est un enjeu
tout simplement d'animation de dynamique
autour des épreuves autour des pistards
qui le mérite bien sa condition de venir
voir une coupe du monde de cyclisme sur
piste
non non non les tarifs se sont sont très
étalée selon étages et pardon selon ce
qu'ont ce qu'on veut une soirée un
week-end mais à partir de 15 euros on
peut venir voir les pistards il ya même
une une tarification avantageuse pour
pour les habitants de saint quentin en
yvelines
une dernière question cette coupe du
monde sept manches de coupe du monde et
d'en voir un peu plus d'un mois
maintenant au vélodrome comme en lançant
se prépare votre fédération acier se
prépare à recevoir l'événement alors
c'est un très gros travail de fond les
organisations sur piste demande
extrêmement de précision parce que les
épreuves s'enchaînent les unes aux
autres très rapidement il faut que tout
soit parfaitement cadré au niveau du
programme et des parties techniques qui
accompagne le programme donc ce travail
il a été démarrée il ya maintenant près
d'un an
on est dans la phase de finalisation je
dirais qu'aujourd'hui ce qui nous
préoccupe le plus en tout cas ce qui
nous anime le plus c'est justement de
remplir ce vélodrome d'amener du monde
autour de nos champions et je rappelle
que cette première manche de coupe du
monde de cyclisme sur piste ucelli se
déroulera au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines du et 19 au 21
octobre infos et billetterie sur le site
de la fédération française de cyclisme
merci michel callot est d'avoir été avec
ne je rappelle que vous êtes le
président de cette fédération française
de cyclisme
un rendez vous régulier à présent que
vous retrouverez tous les mercredis dans
le circuit de journal nous partons dans
les salles obscures du territoire pour
découvrir là leur programmation de la
semaine
premier rendez vous ce soir avec le
cinéma les yeux d'elsa à
saint-cyr-l'ecole les images sont de
patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
pour cette rentrée 2010 8 au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa on va essayer de récupérer
de rattraper des films qu'on a raté cet
été donc vous pourrez redécouvrir ou
voir under the silver lake
film américain avec andrew garfield
black klinsmann qui a vu le grand prix à
cannes
évidemment mais surtout mon petit
chouchou le monde est à toi un film de
romain gavras qui est sorti le 15 août
au coeur de l'été et qui a pas eu le
succès qu'il mérite à mon avis alors
c'est un film qui est soutenu par
vincent cassel et isabelle adjani
vincent cassel joue le rôle de riton qui
sortent du tout juste de prison
une petite frappe voilà un bandit de
deux petits chemins de la pègre
française et puis adjani qui joue le
rôle d'une sorte de flamboyantes
parieuse escroquent qui escroquent même
son fils qui est joué par karim le clos
qui est une seule une vraie révélation
dans ce film
ce jeune homme en fait dans le film joue
le rôle de quelqu'un qui a le rêve de
développer la franchise mister freeze au
maroc
évidemment ça va l'amener dans des
péripéties complètement folle qui font
de ce film un vrai film policier un
thriller une comédie d' aventure
formidable le monde est à toi donc que
vous pourrez retrouver à partir de la
semaine prochaine et pour deux semaines
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa la nouvelle
invitée avec moi en plateau bonsoir
alexis mollet vous êtes le réalisateur
des temps de l'étang l'étang de l'étang
pardon un film hommage à la nature
tourné aux étangs de hollande dans la
commune d hab rivières alors une
projection il sera d'ailleurs proposée
en musique
ce vendredi on en parle juste après
d'abord elle la découverte de ce travail
avec le reportage de jules colis
c'est au sein du premier espaces humides
et aquatiques d'ile-de-france que le
vidéaste alexis boulet a réalisé son
film les temps de l'étang un long
travail présenté dans le cadre du projet
aux artistes le patrimoine du pnr de la
vallée de chevreuse avec l'aide du smage
air et de l'association le ser dans un
lieu très particulier pour l'artiste
c'est un endroit qui regroupait
plusieurs dimensions à la fois la
dimension esthétique la dimension
sauvage
la dimension de la richesse de
biodiversité et puis j'y suis allé avec
des ornithologues faire des comptages
d'oiseaux pour montrer l'évolution de la
biodiversité des étangs pendant une
année
alexis a utilisé la technique du
timelapse afin de rendre compte d'un
mouvement normalement invisibles pour
l'humain j'ai combiné ma passion et mon
envie de devenir dans la nature et cette
technique
deux photos pour monter un projet qui
était de placer des des boîtes
avec des appareils photos dedans avec
des panneaux solaires une batterie un
système autonome bon que l'appareil
photo puisse prendre des photos toutes
les deux minutes en continu pendant
plusieurs années et pour cette
projection
quel meilleur endroit que ces étangs
c'est pourquoi elle se fera directement
dans l'eau le tout accompagné de musique
live
une partie importante au sein du projet
d'alexis quand j'étais à la moitié du
montage il y avait un événement où le
haut lieu à grand bec et un lieu de
résidence d'artistes de faire une
projection du film avec un ami qui est
musicien et que lui demandait si ça
l'intéressait de jouer en live sur sur
cette partie du film une expérience
audiovisuelle qui en plus de s'adresser
à tous sera gratuite
une bonne occasion pour petits et grands
d'aller redécouvrir cet espace naturel
sous un nouvel angle à l'ifsi boulet ce
travail sera donc projeté en plein air
ce vendredi à 19h un ciné concert
directement aux étangs de hollande aubry
hier avec musique en live on va y venir
déjà sur ce lieu des étangs de hollande
on l'a entendue dans ce reportage c'est
un lieu qui vous a inspiré
pourquoi finalement quelques l
atmosphère vous avez pu retrouver sur
place
bah c'est un lieu qui est
particulièrement paisible où il ya peu
de visiteurs et énormément de d'oiseaux
qui viennent qui sont sur place ou des
oiseaux migrateurs et donc c'est un
endroit où on peut venir observer la
nature et se recueillir et contempler
qui est très agréable
comment était mené ce travail dans la
durée on l'a entendu également vous avez
fait appel à des ornithologues notamment
pour mener ce à bien ce travail pas
forcément non j'ai pas fait appel à des
ornithologues j'ai participé à des
comptages d'oiseaux avec des homologues
mai
oui non ce travail il a été mené par ma
sensibilité et aussi j'ai aussi des
connaissances puisque j'ai d une
formation d en écologie voir l'évolution
de ces étangs sur plusieurs mois ça
permet quoi c'est finalement c'est de se
rendre compte aussi de l'évolution de la
nature il ya un vrai angle écologique
derrière une vraie a peut-être un angle
pédagogique aussi auprès des spectateurs
qui pourront le voir ouais après
j'aimerais bien que ça touche à cet
endroit là moi je
je ne sais pas ce que ce que les gens
vont ressentir mais en tout cas oui il
ya quand même ce message un peu
d'essayer de toucher les gens à de
toucher leur sensibilité sur
un écosystème et comment cet écosystème
évolué dans le temps des choses qu'on a
du mal à voir dans notre temps de
réalité quotidienne et donc la voilà
donc de pouvoir montrer que des plantes
bouge que une forêt par exemple
progresse petit à petit et avancer à une
sorte de volonté de recouvrir les temps
donc voilà on a voilà c'est pour montrer
un peu ses mouvements et provoqué cette
sensibilité alors pour la projection de
vendredi pas de voix off met de la
musique en live pour quoi faire ce choix
parce que sa part moins de mon idée de
quand on est dans la nature
de prendre le temps de se taire d'écouté
d'écouter ce qui se passe de regarder ce
qui se passe
et donc je trouvais que la voix off
explicative scientifique venait voile ou
enfin c'était un saint c'est autre chose
et donc là on est quel dans quelque
chose d'un peu hypnotique contemplatif
et donc je trouvais que la musique était
apporte un très bon équilibre
dans cette sensibilité là à l'écran
géant posé sur l'eau voilà on a un écran
géant qui est posé sur l'eau très fin où
l'image est parfaitement dessiné dessus
et les publics et sur sur l'herbe juste
au dessus avec des transats à tous tout
ce qu'il faut et les musiciens qui sont
sur une scène au milieu et qui permette
voilà de jouer en live
en regardant le film on donne le nom de
ses trois musiciens françois michel
mathieu gaulin et glenn martin qui vont
devoir aussi un petit peu se caler sur
sur l'image c'est une performance qui
sera à la maison elle c'est une très
grosse performance
là ça fait déjà deux jours qu'on répète
justement pour ce live pour pouvoir être
bien calée au bon moment et trouver les
thématiques
un peu comme dans du jazz à des
thématiques et après on improvise au
moment où ça se passe ça représente
combien d'années de travail
c'est en j'ai commencé le projet il ya 7
ans j'ai pas travailler pendant sept ans
dessus mais c'est énormément de travail
parce qu'il ya des milliers de photos
qui ont été combinées des mines des
milliers de vidéos
et donc voilà c'est un montage qui
suspend si je mettais tout boutabout
même a pris six mois où l'entrée sera
gratuite
on le précise il faut réserver au
préalable pour venir non en prison de la
soirée le programme s'est on ouvre les
portes à 19 heures au moment où la base
de loisirs ferme
nous on ouvre les portes sur le côté où
il ya un peu d'herbe
de 19h à 20h 20h30 on peut prendre un
pique nique
il y a
un impôt qui offert par la mairie des
bréviaires et la mairie du
perray-en-yvelines et
ensuite la projection commence à 21h
merci alexis boulet d'abord été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes le
réalisateur des temps à 2 les temps un
ciné concert sera d'ailleurs avoir ce
vendredi ça sera à partir de 19h plus
d'informations sur le site internet du
parc naturel régional de la haute vallée
de chevreuse qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran on reste dans la nature pour
refermer ce journal avec un animal qui
pâtit malheureusement d'une mauvaise
image le vautour quatre espèces sont
présentes en france et pour faire
connaître ces rapaces nécessaire à
l'écosystème l'espace rambouillet a
participé le week-end dernier à la
journée internationale du vautour le
reportage de mélanie poker et patrick
jacques de dixmude lui c'est le plus
grand rapace déjà c'est une bonne
formation peut faire jusqu'à 4 mètres 4
mètres d'envergure pour les plus grands
spécimens se condor des andes est l'une
des sept espèces de vautours de l'espace
rambouillet une espèce originaire
d'amérique latine très menacé comme
beaucoup de ses congénères
c'est des espaces qui sont mal aimés du
fait de bon là c'est un peu bizarre
comme oiseaux ça fait peur
il ya tout l'imaginaire qui va règles du
charognard un carnivore qui mangent des
cadaves ça fait beaucoup pour un trésor
pour redonner ses lettres de noblesse
aux rapaces l'espace rambouillet a
participé pour la deuxième fois à la
journée internationale du vautour les
retours c'est un peu chez les
équarrisseurs de la nature sur les
vêtements de la nature dans le sens au
grâce à eux il n'y a pas de maladies qui
se répandent dans nos espaces naturels
dans nos montagnes
elle c'est un peu la fin de la chaîne
alimentaire démonstration échanges avec
les fauconniers soutien de programmes
les vautours fauves moine ou encore pape
ont séduit alors le retour de l'himalaya
c'est le grand tu peux voir là tu vois
qu'il vienne le qui vient de lever la
pâte comme ça et c'est très
impressionnant animal que j'aime
beaucoup
globalement les rapaces parce que c'est
des animaux qui volent
une manière magnifique quoi et sont très
impressionnants très gros j'aime bien
c'est une espèce protégée et c'est beau
et j'aime bien aller voir l'espace
rambouillet la france accueille quatre
espèces différentes
seuls les vautours fauves ne sont pas
menacés c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
merci de votre fidélité le replay et les
reportages sont à consulter sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]